thank you please be seated.
This hearing is now convene. For
those of you who don't know me
and assembly member on and I'm
lucky to have him.
At thank you for attending this
informational hearing of for the
select committee on career
technical education and building
a twenty first century workforce
many of you have been to our
hearings before.
I also want to think
assemblymember Luis Rivas for
coming today and she sits on
labor and employment committee
she also sits with me on revenue
and tax --
And I wanna thank you for being
here with us today.
I'm working from during my time
in the assembly to champion
career technical education and
workforce development because
the roles of these issues play
in California in securing.
Living wage not living wage job
it's but careers.
I look forward to continuing
that work with assembly member
Reavis --
But what as we all know no
matter what community workforce
is vital.
Today we we will explore public
policy is to California report
which highlights the potential.
By twenty five of who will need.
HM but this it's about the story.
For those of you who know who
anyone who's ever heard me speak
before recently California made
a significant investment into C.
T. and workforce development
assembly bill sixteen oh to a
budget trailer bill established
a strong workforce development
program.
Allocating two hundred million
dollars for that program this
pastor the legislature approved
assembly bill eighteen oh eight
which provided a further a
hundred and fifty million
dollars for career technical
education programs.
This funding is much needed
support for career technical
education but is not the only
factor.
California must better match it
supply of labor with demand.
Information chair at sharing in
do driven investments are
critical in this endeavor and we
must examine how we at the state
can facilitate this partnership.
That a comprehensive and
collaborative effort across
industry educational
institutions and workforce
development organizations
California risk creating a
polarized economy of has and has
not.
Such a realisation serves no one
and we must ensure all
Californians have the necessary
skills to secure employment that
provide economic security for
their families --
An apparent form a foundation
for robust economy and of course
we really aren't we need to
focus on expanding our middle
class.
I will now turn over to assembly
member lose Reavis for her
opening remarks thank you again
for being here.
Thank you assembly with --
When they Burke and thank you
for everybody that's here today --
Very excited to be here --
This is the topic that I really
care about and I'm.
I'm proud to be here to join --
Assembly member Burke --
In her work --
I'd also like to thank the city
of Lawndale and the Lawndale
community center for hosting us
today -- So
I represent the thirty ninth
assembly district which is in
the north the San Fernando
Valley.
It includes --
Several communities like a claim --
Send Bally on the city of San
Fernando is in my district --
I grew up in this district and
when I was a kid --
The north the San Fernando
Valley had a lot of
manufacturing and aerospace jobs
so we had a price Pfister plant --
Down the street from my
elementary school that made
faucets that were union jobs --
High skilled workers we had
Lockheed --
And other men aerospace industry --
And most people were able
[inaudible]
In home you know a base you know
small basic home but and I think
since we lost a lot those jobs
and a lot of the companies left
that area --
That community hasn't recovered --
And that this is one of the
reasons I'm very interested --
In the topic.
You know today most of my
district is considered a
disadvantaged community --
Other issues that we have --
That come along with that --
There's this week the LA times
is doing a series.
On child poverty in my district
and focused on an elementary
school that I attended --
So something I'm very passionate
about is --
Homeless children --
But a lot of the reason some of
these families are homeless is
because there aren't high
skilled jobs --
That P. good weight is anymore
in that community --
You know I believe that you know
city is vital not only to help
in our state's economy.
But also to help uplift
communities like mine.
By and you know as a former
educator myself you know I'm the
founder of a nonprofit --
That teaches stem education to
girls and hands on stand with
computer science wood working
you know this lot lots of highs
highly skilled --
You're preparing them for high
school careers --
You know my background I studied
electrical engineering I also
worked in manufacturing --
Right out of college and a lot
of the people that I worked with --
At the company were didn't have
a college education but they
were trained on a specific skill.
And were paid a living wage --
And so I'd love that for Los
Angeles our economy our Ste our
whole state economy. To have
that again to you know what can
we do what are the needs and
that's why I'm interested in
learning from you.
On what are the needs out there
how can we better coordinate --
What can we do estate
legislators --
To bring these jobs to our
communities.
So again I'd like to thank
assembly member Burke city of
Lawndale the panelists.
And I look forward to learning
from you today [inaudible]
Thanks.
Thank you assembly member
reviews and also assembly member
Gipson will dip in at some point
will let him have his opening
remarks when he gets here but
before we begin we those who
want to participate in and
public comment there's a sign in
sheet in the back.
I think it's at the back table
for those of you who want to
sign in --
We have additional changes to
the agenda Ernesto Medrano will
be filling in for run Miller
from LA O. C. building trades
council.
And Dr Virginia Rappe will be
speaking on behalf of El Camino
college in place of Adrin
Estrada.
We will now begin with our first
panel.
The kitchens [inaudible]
For first [inaudible]
So are [inaudible] One of okay
okay.
So. For our first panel to start
we have Serra bond director of
research and senior fellow of
the public public policy
institute of California.
Thank you so much and thank you
assembly member Burke for
convening this hearing and for
including PP I see for those in
the audience who aren't familiar
with PP I see we are that public
policy institute of California.
A non partisan independent
research institute devoted to
studying policy issues critical
to California and work forces at
the top of our list so I'm
really pleased to be here today.
Recently PP I see surveyed
Californians on issues of higher
education and the workforce and
we found that 75% of
Californians believe our public
higher education system is vital.
To of the quality of life here
and economic vitality of
California and not only that
they also 75%.
And I think that this should be
a high or very high priority for
the next.
The the new governor so this is
a really timely conversation
right after the election.
So thank you for convening this --
Imprint.
The majority of future jobs in
California will require at least
some college training about a
third about his degree or higher
in about a third community
college training.
And this --
Shift is the result of you know
long term trends in our economy
towards a knowledge based
economy.
That effects not just what you
jobs are created in California
and the skill requirements there
but also the skill requirements
in jobs that are already on line
in our economy.
In addition two empty so in in
addition to improving kind of
job availability I'm having a
college degree or some college
training also increase it
incredibly improve access to
better paying careers for
Californians.
This chart which I'm sorry it
might be hard for some of you to
see -- Shows
the top ten job wrote that is
projected of through.
Twenty twenty six and what you
see is another result of the
long term trends toward the
knowledge based economy that.
Has increased the gap in
earnings --
Ford between jobs that have
require a college credential and
those that do not.
So among these top ten you see a
handful of careers in mainly
service sectors --
That pay less than thirty five
thousand dollars a year jobs
like personal care aides.
Food preparation labor --
And material movers --
These jobs do not require.
A college education.
At the other extreme you see a
handful of positions like
software developers registered
nurse thing --
Operations managers market
researchers --
Earning three to four times as
much as those lower skilled
positions --
And of course these are jobs and
careers that require college
education and this trend shows
no sign of abating.
In fact it could become more
extreme with changes in a high
and robotics and other --
Item on the nation --
That is likely to to do what
we're likely to see in our
economy with a large public
higher education system is quite
a challenge --
In being responsive to what the
work force and requires for the
future and also being responsive
to student needs because the
future of labor force in
California.
Is comprised of workers that are
much more diverse than the
current labor force --
And from groups that have
typically historically --
And she to lower levels of
education beyond high school.
California has made I would just
say a lot of progress and and
improving access and college
attainment for these groups but
there's still room to improve.
And I think --
Community colleges are critical
to meeting that need because
they really are the point of
entry for most Californians
pursuing education beyond high
school --
And they serve about three times
as many students as the state
that the CSU and you see systems
combined.
If you just look at career
technical programs this gives
you a bit of a snapshot of the
students that are pursuing
education in that round.
It's a very diverse group of
students in terms of their
ethnic background they tend to
be low income the majority
anyway --
And there's a diverse range of
students --
Pursuing CT training and and the
California community college
system on the average age of the
student is thirty so we're not
is that these programs actually
serve a wide range of
backgrounds from recent high
school graduates to stranded
workers to older workers in need
of retraining.
And the train as we know --
For a wide variety of important
careers in industry sectors.
And CT to me is really --
The workforce needs as you as
you mentioned in your opening
comments because it is so it is
really the fastest way. To get
that training that helps
students improve their economic
outcomes and helps our state
meet its workforce means --
I would just add that and
there's now a wealth of research
evidence on the economic pay off
to see TV credentials this
charges shows the wage return
for students to achieve CT
credentials --
In the California system and it
you know the the kind of pay off
that they earn --
In the labor market depends on
the length of the credential the
highest from a an associate's
degree --
And abating a little bit --
For shorter term certificates
that can be earned say less than
a year but none the less the
economic returns are still
positive.
But the program choice also
matters a lot if you if you take
health programs out of this
calculation you can see that the
the economic return to students
is much lower.
So the choice of the program for
students almost as important in
a lot of ways as whether take to
pursue college training at all.
And I would commend the to the
chancellor's office in the
California community college
system for making this salary
information publicly available
on their website.
Tools like the salary server
it's really helpful for students
to think about what at what this
training might get them in terms
of labor market opportunities
it's also of course really
important for policy makers.
Who are --
Looking to assess the
effectiveness of investments in
CT.
But when I look at those numbers --
Programs against each other in
terms of their just kind of
before after return on
investment.
Because of what really we need
to think about are improving
long term economic outcomes and
mobility for students and and
workers in California and
there's actually many pathways.
That can take students to better
career outcomes.
In our research at PP I see
we've looked at how students
staff credentials so a lot of
students actually start --
By earning a short term
certificate that can be and in
less than a year that was the
lowest wage return that you saw
on the previous charts.
A lot of students start their
but some of those who --
Stack a credential on top of
that eventually catch up --
To students who start with the
higher values a associates
degree the that's the good news
the the challenges that not a
lot of students actually do that
and not a lot of programs seem
to be set up to intentionally
help students move along a clear
pathway.
But that's an active area that
the colleges are working on I
wanted -- To
conclude with this chart that
shows that there are.
Many pathways that can take
students from --
You know kind of a low through
CT training and looking we
looked at just that --
Students and health programs
students you started by earning
a high value certificate or
speaks give me a high value --
Degree lack an associate's
degree in nursing.
We see their wages increase of
rapidly and substantially by
about three times after learning
that degree students to start
with the lower value credential
like a short term certificate if
they continue on that career
pathway.
That bottom line eventually
catches up to the students who
started on a different pathway
so I just wanted to reinforce
this point there are many.
Ways students can I'm.
Konami billeting program.
Sign them do that.
Really active way --
Prove upward mobility in
California and just in closing --
I would reiterate that --
These state investments in CT
clearly have benefits for
students but that benefit is
contingent on our programs being
geared towards meeting workforce
needs of the future so the
partnership with business is
really critical --
In ensuring that state
investments and students
investments of time --
Really pay off in terms of
expanding economic outcomes
[inaudible]
Thank you much.
You mentioned --
The that there are several
pathways rate that students take.
On are those recommended by the
community college or did you
just find that the students just
kind of made their way through.
These pathways.
It out on their own.
That's a great question so what
we've done is to try to look
across the system and what
pathways are offered and there's
really a wide range across
colleges even in the same
similar kind of industry or
occupational area you see lots
of different structures for how
students.
Might make it through a program
and this is an active area where
colleges are trying to create
better pathways through the
guided pathways movement in
strong work for the best.
So I would say that you know
will probably likely to see and
how.
Who is our does?
You know that there are some
really stand out clearly lay out
a career progression for
students and what courses they
need to take what credentials
they'll earn.
And in other cases it's kind of
looks like a choose your own
adventure and you see that
reflected in what students
actually do so we looked at what
students have done over the last
ten fifteen years.
And the combinations of prevents
that they are in our you know
the kind of across.
Quite a range of what they
combine --
Both in terms of kind of looking
like it's related to upward
mobility are up I'd upward
career progression or not --
And so I think there's a lot of
room for improvement there we
found that students who programs
I should say --
That are a really ext with a
career progression --
Improve student outcomes to a
very large extent --
I think the exact percentage was
about you know they improve the
students odds of completing a
second degree by about 16% which
is really large in this round --
So there's a lot of promise
there to improve.
And the script pathway programs
[inaudible]
Thank you.
And when you look at when you
look at the opportunity of
putting public and private
putting the community colleges
together with some of the
industry's or actually specific
companies where do you see the
possibility --
For collaboration --
That we haven't taken advantage
of so much yet.
That's a great question which I
actually would like to know the
answer to but don't I I'm hoping
that some of the other panels
might address that as well.
And you know we we see what we
want to you looks kind of to get
the state wide picture of what's
offered.
And your range of apprentices
apprenticeship programs in
credential --
Geared toward certain industries --
But we didn't look we we work on
the ground enough to know
exactly kind of the potential
for them for what.
Great thank you that was I mean
yanking pages out of your
presentation keep for later when
I quote them hopefully and
committee sometime.
Thank you for being here thank
you [inaudible]
That.
All right well now have our
second panel come forward.
Justin a carrying Christos and
doctor almost laws are jandal
internet [inaudible]
The five and Mister Dawson if
you'll start [inaudible]
Right.
Yes okay well first of all you --
For inviting us to this event is
a great event of the time is
perfect for chevron.
And a lot of passion here --
But just for introduction first
also then whichever for eighteen
years --
Started a shovel in the year two
thousand in operations the exact
type of workforce that.
Cash around trying to develop
our needs for so having this
year right now is a to have some
conversation about it and how we
can board --
What about the first lights
[inaudible]
See.
Took a little bit about our
Democrat press seven enough
again does --
Just briefly before I really
dive into where our needs are
with operations training program.
And where we see our needs are
for the future --
Just briefly a total
compensation --
For all of our employees in two
thousand sixteen was measured at
a hundred and eighty eight
million --
Average hourly wages --
For full time operations a main
supply.
Route forty dollars per hour.
And that's it does not including
you know average of 17% of
annual overtime payment
contractor wages we typically
bring in roughly around --
Four to five hundred routine
contractors per year.
Averaging around the forty to
forty five dollars per hour --
Of rate.
And and a snapshot of what I
diversity --
Of us --
Plate looks like over seven US
agenda --
Gender male to female ratio 85%
215% -- The
generation --
Played. Three to twelve
millennials born in eighty eight
the Chen x.'ers fortunate --
Thirty nine in the baby boomer
generation.
And then you see where Reyes
plays --
We're races at as far as
adversity 51% white. 10% --
Asian 27% Hispanic and a percent --
African American.
Someone non visible diversity
statistics --
Pretty darn it leads us.
Spaces for education is
concerned 27%.
Of our workforce are actually
high school graduates --
28% -- Come
out with a degree or some sort
of occasional degree war where
27% example.
We're pretty pretty equally
space there.
Our persist reading program --
SO four seven also gonna
operations remember pretty open
application process.
All of our training is done
internally.
It's all done in house --
Where we will like to target
however is from P. tech
institutions that are in our
surrounding area?
And when I see the timing is
perfect because right now we're
on a actual learning journey to
understand exactly what's.
Happening in our surrounding
communities.
What committee colleges actually
offer P. tech programs what
their programs look like --
How successful are there --
What's your student demographics
of like --
We had a great opportunity to
visit a couple of different
purposes over the last month so.
That that that the timing is
right right now area and also --
Coastline community college
which is actually an Orange
County.
What we would like to do going
forward is to understand what
additional campuses in the
nearby areas?
That you know reflect the our
surrounding communities that we
can also leverage your P. tech
programs offer for bring it into
more skillful workforce to shop
and also get the our application
process is pretty linking.
You know us about six months --
That's from the time from
applying for jobs. To actually
stepping foot into the door
right so it's a pretty lengthy
process we have a two month
orientation including a two
month -- As
I to what orientation which
includes basic operator training
and then you have a two month.
You know jobs fifty specific
training program so if you look
at it.
All together is about a ten
month term of process is pretty
pretty lengthy.
What we're gonna do really is
looking a little more efficient
with a Cup time?
How can we leverage what P. tech
from offering so that we're
doing so much and have?
And we're not [inaudible]
Work [inaudible]
For you know.
We don't know too much about
what the totals offering from
community colleges so that's the
reason why we're on a learning
to any right now --
Our needs are truly based off
you know able to target.
A more skilled --
Workforce by leveraging what
Peter programs could offer us
want to reduce the timeline.
That it that it takes to bring
somebody actually into.
The workforce and being --
You know --
A productive employee and also
at the same time decrease
employee turnover by targeting
those who actually want to be in
the P. tech industry P. tech
meeting.
Process together process
technology.
Also we're seeing is as far as
in is a shift in --
I guess for lack of better words
generations right.
A large portion of our workforce
right now or senior employees
and as they you know retire on
out with it you know normal
attrition.
We have a big gap between those
employees and the newer
employees that were bringing in.
So our customer demand is
getting a little bit stronger
although the numbers are.
Growing substantially you're
staying around the same.
Twenty to thirty annually.
But as we're losing our senior
staff that that ranging between
of skilled workforce or
experience in our workforce is
dropping significant.
So.
That's a big reason why we need
to bring in a workforce that
more skilled coming in so that
they can.
Become more productive quicker --
For future.
You know for several we want to
increase the visibility
evaluation of P. tech program so
hopefully you know with --
Increasing the conversations
with us and groups like this and
most of all the with the South
Bay with we can continue to do
that --
Partner with committee because
to help develop a bigger talent
pool and maybe even.
Play a role in how they're
programs actually developed and
how the programs can be
successful.
And then just continue to
partner with those workers is to
keep them never bring going for
so. Seven my last question.
I was so late to the and to ask
a question.
Well I do have a quick question
because it also everyone can
answer this question so fast you
know the rest of you you all can
answer Sir --
Still I am we are trying to
figure out actually actively
trying to figure out how to
create that connection between
the community colleges and
private industry and so my
question to you would be as
someone in that process.
What would make it easier for
you to make that connection
between call just to make sure
that they are actually preparing?
Folks for your industry.
What what would actually make it
easier to make that transition
to working with the community
colleges from my perspective but
they will make it easier?
If we had a better conduit.
Between us and knowing exactly
what's out there --
Right now even though I visited
three different campuses of the
last couple of months.
It was --
Was colleges a taken to side
right type labor group really
didn't know exactly who was out
there what campuses are out
there.
Won't even by the ones that we
knew of had just by word of
mouth but if we had a actual
stable proper conduct.
That can tell the tape you know
so we just college --
Camino college --
Ellie Harper college right --
That we can draw from.
And they're successful that'll
be a big game changer for us.
Thank you [inaudible]
That.
But then I would one piggy back
on that I absolutely agree I
think having.
A better conduit and
intermediary that can help
facilitate those business
education partnerships --
I think regional business
organizations are starting to
play a critical role in this --
In this regard I often joke that --
And I'm trying legal I speak
business education and workforce
Senate and acquired skill set.
And sometimes the educators on
the ground are so intent and
their primary focus that being
able to do that code switching
where they can directly
interface with employers or
really understand their names --
Is sometimes daunting and
difficult as well as trying to
more deeply a line the systems
in in a way in which I mean they
and they funds we're ready to
engage that means.
Today tomorrow within the next
week or systems don't always
aren't always as nimble and
ready to respond --
To the degree that are employers
are ready to engage to somehow
if we can incentivize those
types of behavior which I think.
We've done a superb job in over.
Several of pieces of legislation
last couple years I've tried to
elicit these types a B. average
per systems I think would be
much further along [inaudible]
Contract but thank you work in
progress [inaudible]
That's where.
Justin I do want to go --
Is like a centers of it's are
next panelist is Justina the
Cooley Cooper okay I'm
recruiting director for
manufacturing a production at
face at as well K..
Yes my name.
I and the recruiting manager
asking sacks for manufacturing
production for all our product
lines --
Today I'd like to discuss
[inaudible]
Thank you.
At sixty six in general was
founded in two thousand its you
by can one mosque --
Currently as we stand today were
about six thousand employees we
have about twelve billion
dollars in business contracts
and we've had sixty five
successful flights so that's a
really exciting time for us as
we are growing. For such a young
organization compared to our
members --
Currently we have a few vehicles
that were launching right now so
we have our falcon.
Nine falcon heavy cargo driving
and soon to be pre dragon and
that will be for manned flight.
Falcon nine has been
successfully launched sixty two
again it's been an incredible
feat for us just because it was
a historic moment in two
thousand and twelve when we were
the first commercial spacecraft
to make it to the international
space station delivering cargo
and then also bringing cargo
back.
Home safely back to earth so
that has been a huge piece in
terms of our success.
Lately --
The next vehicle that we're
building right out as you seen
falcon having made its premiere
this year.
And it's the world's most
powerful operational launch
vehicle.
Equals approximately eighteen
seven forty seven aircraft.
Incredibly powerful and that
would be to deliver larger
payloads to orbits. For the next
couple that were having --
Is for dragon so for cargo
tracking we have for flight
proven mission.
Except --
And that it --
NASA recently announced this
year that we wine [inaudible]
Black.
Now the asset to the
international space station in
our were dragon spacecraft.
At the first. One is gonna be
inch would June twenty nineteen
to the I. S. S. and that's gonna
be !n ma'am.
From there and then the next
will be for June twenty nineteen
for a demo to mission and that
will be managed with this.
Asheron's and their since the
beginning of two thousand and
seventeen physics as represented
over 60% of all U. S. orbital
watches with thirty six
completed mission.
So far in twenty eighteen
SpaceX's achieve the fastest
launching its in its history
launching more than our domestic
or international competitors.
Have lunch with eighteen likes
so far --
This year which is huge and we
have about twenty to plan for
this year so we have a couple
more coming out. To date
SpaceX's this actually landed
[inaudible]
Thirty exciting [inaudible]
From there.
Sorry because project working on
next is starship.
Chau starship is this next
generation launch system is
fully reusable.
And is designed to provide cost
effective and reliable launch
services for our customers and
to serve as an interplanetary
transport system.
The first opportunity lunch
cargo mission to Mars is.
Twenty twenty two followed by
the first crude mission in.
Twenty twenty four currently
less than 5% of SpaceX's
resources are currently being
spent on starship but that will
change quite significantly with
the years to come.
We're looking for top talent in
those with a passion for mission
SpaceX looks for people who love
text. To speech challenge the
status quo and solve problems.
Like to see strong academics but
what's equally important to this
is also.
Individuals getting involved in
participation groups and clubs
allow you develop a process
product goal.
We want people who worked to
solve problems and who enjoy
experimenting with different
solutions within the team based
setting.
Strong and that makes our part
because you will be making very
technical decisions at SpaceX so
what you learn in school will
apply to you in the juggling
multiple projects.
So bounce academics and hands on
experience is a key for us.
The work that we do is very
challenging however it's
incredibly rewarding because we
are contributing to something
much larger than ourselves.
The LA area offers many
opportunities for a diverse
workforce a recruiting teams
look all over the country for
the best and we have hard many
lovely. For trade school
specifically where we are
succeeding are with the
instructors that have invested
their time with us so we have
hiring managers that.
Partner with them to help create
a curriculum space access --
For the work that we do.
We have donated expired
materials to those schools and
have hired me right after
graduation what we seem from
those individuals they are
definitely thriving in our
environment.
Also see much success with
individuals with air frame and
power plant licenses however one
of the main issues is that can
make can be quite expensive
obtaining that license.
Generally a two year program.
Can cost anywhere from
200-002-50000.
From and as a a accredited
program.
If there was any way to reduce
the costs we would have a much
larger candidate pool.
It's helpful for the state's
invest in the training and
education programs in the
community trust the region's
develop more town locally.
Los Angeles is a great place
first attracted retain talent
we're proud to have our
headquarters located in
Hawthorne.
And we're looking forward to
more for the future.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm willing to give --
Assembly member gets and a
chance to do of our acts that I
have questions about that your
trade school environment.
Of slim say hi.
First of all thank you very much
to our that your woman into the
committee a sorry for my absence
or for my tardiness rather.
But this is an important topic
for me specially looking at two
thousand nineteen working --
To really --
Have a real in depth robust
conversation as it relates to
correct technical education
which is very very important --
And looking for to out of his
today's means a thank you good
is the chair.
Thanks for being here assembly
member Gipson up so I do can you
tell us a little bit more about
the jobs that are coming out of
your partnership with the trade
schools. To some of the
positions we've hired for our
propulsion technicians --
Structures technicians
composites technicians and with
composites it's definitely a
very specialized skills that in
terms of the material that we
use so that's why we decided to
donate those to the schools.
That has worked out incredibly
well for them to be hands on our
her managers actually show up on
site and work with the
instructors from there to create
this program so --
For the efforts that we've done
locally it's worked out
incredibly well for us in terms
of potentially creating an
apprenticeship program for
example.
But for the individuals that
have worked their income
straight out they've done
extremely well and I'm I'm in.
And how did you make that
decision to do that. To partner
with the trade schools.
We saw so many it in our work
force in general at space that
they actually do come out from a
lot of the trade schools because
they have an local to the area
so.
Just hearing from word of mouth
of what programs are becoming or
what courses they've taken I
just definitely peaked in
interest in to us to go check
that out.
Thank you.
For anyone any questions.
Yeah my questions also related
how you got started.
With those partnership --
You just said it was word of now
what yeah I mean.
Just sure is there anyone that
could have helped.
Create that partnership like we
had said like that.
I would probably.
You know is that whether someone
that helped or did you just do
the outreach center average
ourselves so sometimes you know.
We hear things were very curious
and as recruiters are very
curious in terms of what else is
out there --
It was a great opportunity for
us literally just given the
calls this call a call --
And then feeding that into the
were able to pass this out to
the appropriate.
Instructors at their schools for
us a bill that partnership.
So -- They
it's been great so far
everybody's been very welcoming
and writes us coming over there
and we've also bring them over
on sites you.
Take a tour and see firsthand
what we deal just because we
built over.
75% of the of on site so it's
it's quite exciting in terms of
the life that we live.
In the factory [inaudible]
Thank you.
Any other questions [inaudible]
Then.
Thank you very much thanks for
being here and I have the best
companies in my district with
that --
Knowing her from doctor cells
are.
Good afternoon everyone in
delighted a join you here today
and thank you assembly member
Burke and assembly member I
request for hosting at this
competing.
I'm I I have the privilege today
of representing the California
workforce development board of
the first let me tell you a
little bit about myself my name
is almost hours arm a senior
vice president at the LA area
chamber of commerce and we river
represents sixteen hundred
member companies --
In the greater LA basin --
In I want to share with you a
little bit about what the state
board has done --
In both through policy into
investments to really help
foment stronger connections
between our educational
institution a workforce
development board's and our
providers --
To our employers particularly
those who --
Hi hi.
Hi way tie skill demands --
In our region --
So several years ago when we
embarked in the development of
our state wide strategic plan it
was really with the notion.
Around how can we better
strength in interesting mental
efforts between our workforce
development board's in our
community colleges an arcade.
A K. twelve adults system.
And work that then can help
provide guideposts for regional
economies in a regional efforts --
As a result of that work.
There really has --
Created that de um.
At the plan to ensure that
increasingly our systems are
better connecting or better
online mean.
Are --
Building economies of scale and
minimizing duplication and
maximizing effort --
Manager Dan will speak to this a
little bit in terms of their
regional planning efforts are
currently under way in ensuring
that are seven workforce
development board's here in LA
county.
Are --
Better aligned and more
strategic in terms of how their
interfacing with regional
employers much of which came out
of of the state wide strategic
plan -- But
I think what it really --
Lends itself to it's just the
the continued focus around if
you're really going to address
issues as it relates to
individuals who --
Have multiple barriers to
employment we really need to
ensure that all of our systems.
All of our partners are growing
in the same --
To is who we want to deeply
engage with --
When a point to at least --
For different initiatives that
have been funded through --
One of three of which is funded
through the governor's --
Discretionary funding and one of
which which was just codified a
couple of years ago and where
there is currently --
Appropriations going to be
provided to ensure that we
continue --
To focused around this work --
So the first being the sling
shot initiative --
Which seeks to collaborative
efforts between employers
industry government workforce
economic development.
On educational partners within
the region to identify and solve
employment challenges --
In the last --
Fiscal year the state invested
six point one million dollars in
the sling shot initiatives --
Which I know came to the LA
region a particularly focused on
health care and we've done
others throughout the state --
That have really done this work
and I think what it really
points to and what the resources
of been for it to really invite
and a pool for innovation within
our region --
And give our our workforce
development board's and others
the creativity to start to
address these issues and to
really go beyond silos --
To ensure that we are eliciting
for some of the best practices --
So kudos to the state board and
others who really brought a
visionary mindset to this and
have really in many ways.
I'm use these resources to
incentivize --
These innovative behaviors --
The second is a workforce
accelerator find --
And similarly --
As governor discretionary
funding.
Provided six million dollars in
two and twenty eighteen decks
that design develop and
implement and accelerate --
Employment and reemployment
strategies of for our our
hardest to serve job seekers --
And similarly test for types of
innovations and solutions that
try to address --
These barriers to employment --
And then lastly --
Investments in the high road
training partnerships --
In these have been focused
around there been --
Eight demonstration projects
that have I'm in this is --
Uniquely focused around --
The delivery of equity
sustainability and job quality
for again --
Some of are harder to serve
populations and ensuring that.
We are --
Incentivizing.
These are implementing the
strong.
That have really range of from
transportation to health care
projects and another efforts --
So again I am twenty two three
discrete of funding streams that
have really sought to engage
employers resources that are
available that in many ways
invites employers to be not only
the table but help try these
innovative partnerships.
Again working across our respect
silos -- To
ensure that we're getting a
higher yield these types of
investments and really be an
incubator for our some success
successful --
Initiatives --
Lastly all point to AB --
Eleven eleven this was led by
the California workforce assist
California workforce association
NWA -- Was
codified more than resources for
A. B. eleven of and and it's a
fifteen million dollar grant
program.
That will --
Encouraged and community based
on his agents to work with its
workforce development board's.
In --
Identifying of resources for
individuals with barriers to
employment and where we can
better serve --
These populations --
There are a series of
stakeholder meetings that will
be scheduled this.
I'm with the expectation that
the request for proposals will
be made available --
Next spring so just something to
keep an eye on in terms of as
this legislation is forward in
Nazareth been resources
appropriated what can we glean --
From these initiatives that can
that we should then be working.
Terms of helping to bring the
scale --
Create a critical mass of
opportunities for individuals
that we need to serve.
I will also add particularly as
it relates --
To workforce accelerator and
sling shot --
There has been a pushed around
how to weave badly we these
initiatives in trying to glean
take away.
Not necessarily assess how well
they work but what it what is it
that we can take from this
particular initiative that then
we could look towards as pillars
of effective practices that we
might want invest.
So A. Posner happening cost.
I have a change of the okay a
question I have a question so
okay so the money will so.
I have a couple questions one
what did the engagement look
like so I hear the there was
money allocated to these
programs one question would be
why did the engagement with
employers look like and what was
the outcome and what was.
The sort of again passage and
okay.
And there was one of the funded
projects in okay to it with a
great app.
So that's made one of that's my
question is what to the
engagement look like how they
were employer how are employers
found on the city of chevron
here that want to participate in
some of these things.
Well the the the the one that --
Was referred to was the health
care coordination grant what
happened together and we did you
tell us what you need.
We're gonna tell you what you
need you tell us what you mean
what came out was que is
coordination.
So -- That
started a long string of
discussions and coordination and
how to do that.
And we found a couple colleges.
That were able --
To this space specifically
trained for the curriculum that
the employers wide.
And we contracted with those --
Hospitals we had lots of help
from the hospital association.
Who survey there --
Members and based on that.
We've filled up the class and we
have a waiting list for people
that want to go into that so it
took awhile to get. To to get it
all going but that's how come
that's how it started.
We said what do you want they
told us we contracted with the
hospital association.
We set them down with all their
and their nurse practitioners to
tell us what to the curriculum
look like.
Develop the curriculum.
And identified those colleges
that were able to teach.
And I remember when you do that
that was last year you started.
Last year we were in mounting it
last or anything --
And then my next question is for
those who want --
To be part of these programs for
the students.
Whatever age that student may be --
What kind of --
Assistance have we what kind of
funds and we provided to assist
them in being able to actually
take the program to go so often
transportation is an issue or
having to take off work isn't
issues so have we provided on
any sort of state level three
workforce development board's.
Up something to alleviate some
of the strains.
So for that particular program
it's a little different because
that particular program there
was a limited number of slots
and we feel that and many of
those people are already working.
In lower jobs so right so there
is is basically incumbent
workers that were able --
To to they already had
transportation.
But in our regular programs the
regular corps might be that we
get from the state federal
government through the state is
we have support services
available to put people in those
programs using our base
allocation.
Allocation so there's no
separate allocation and just to
give an order of magnitude in
terms of at least the workforce
accelerator find and it has been
in place. For several years now.
The state is invested about
forty million --
Grant initiative --
But they've awarded a hundred
and twenty five grand.
And certain about fourteen
thousand participants statewide --
I think that you know.
The point being that I think
there's an opportunity to double
serve for individuals and
obviously --
The order magnitude is greater
than the resources that are
currently being invested --
But I think what this points to
is where I think in many ways
the state board is --
Hello.
I'm dina be innovative in terms
of how it it's making its
investment than trying to offer
the best practices in hopes that.
Not only do.
Lessons but also ways in which
we might work.
His efforts scale.
And then my last post for it and
and you guys feel free.
To wondering do you data on any
of our because some of these
programs have it listed do you
have any date on on their six
Sir.
Are the their this.
Suddenly conducting an elevation
of these initiatives I believe
that's under way but now that.
It's been analyze just yet but
I'm only in the near future --
You mentioned [inaudible]
That you.
The example that you gave with
the health.
Hospital assistant and how you
got together. To develop correct.
Graham -- Is
that are those programs at to be
specific to the a run to the
read.
Or are then they able to be
taken to another part of the
state as an example a like a
already kids that's ready. To go.
Aye aye.
I think it it is a package is
ready to go but what we were
looking at primarily was the
only sin --
An Orange County only basins as
far the demand for those
particular jobs what they are
across the state I don't
remember.
But certainly the package in the
information is available to
distribute and to replicate.
So if there were a demand in
another part of the state arms.
To certain they don't have to
start over rate no no no no they
should start over okay.
And actually --
And I'm sure Dân knows that
this particular initiative as
actually put out --
Eighty in evaluation of its own
work and has a full report in
terms of what they learned from.
The degree to get access to that.
Because as we look a think what
you know some of the goal I know
like it's some of my goal is to
really figure out how.
To make that process easier how
to find out where the gaps are
regionally these tend to be
regional issues they can be
duplicated in other regions but
I know ag has had some great
success with their workforce
development board's and some of
their local issues and you had
some.
Great success but to not have to
restart that process every time.
I thinks incredibly important
and how we still a tape that
connection --
Not just to employers but the
connection on what works what
doesn't and how we streamline
that process so that we can be
more efficient and then be able
to push more money to it is kind
of the goal of of this committee.
As one of just waiting and I
think --
With --
Being here he a stake in the
chair of the entire association
say the California association
of so I think Jeff to be a great
kh do it because of the work
that you do in.
Your ship you provide.
Yeah certainly you can pull
everyone together so that we can
making sure that resources and
collaboration is is is out there
so that we can make sure to
actually see what's.
Available because sometimes we
don't we get our silos and we
don't know what the right hand
or left hand is doing.
And I think --
Certainly when you're leadership
capacity you can pull people one
false the cracks.
Thank you I'll do my best --
To Jess yesterday.
We're just together and
Bakersfield having conversation
about all the jobs of that
Bakersfield has available and
transporting people from the Los
Angeles basin area. To relocate
and a lot of ways --
To Bakersfield and take on some
of those job responses of Jan I
was gather --
Yesterday cities leadership and
all input by and by the way
we're ready to go.
Deals always ready to go.
Leaders of thank you on that
note.
Dan vocal.
Okay thank you very much
assembly woman --
It's so difficult even know
where to start you you you
broach the question before about
how to the connections how the
connections made between --
The the the community colleges
and education and the businesses
and vice versa.
Right before your very knows
there are forty five workforce
boards in California.
Those workforce boards of the
ones that they are the glue. To
be able to connect those
businesses to those educational
institutions and to the
educational institutions to the
employers where they're some of
the community colleges are
working very closely with us El
Camino is here today I see El
Camino is --
We were it we're have a contract
ending with El Camino one of the
strong work force funds at the
chancellor's office provides.
Well.
That's what community because
reinvent the wheel is work with
the existing organizations that
can do that.
And is such as what El Camino is
doing and and other great
community colleges are doing.
The strong work force money is
is very much needed and that the
federal dollars that have come
down for work for us over the
past decade has been cut roughly
50%.
So any additional funds like
that strong work force or like
what leases --
Cells are mentioned about AB one
one one one because a year
leadership --
Assembly woman and Mike Gipson
leadership that was able to pass
a will be getting additional
resources which will help
mitigate the losses at the
federal level.
So that's that's one thing.
Another thing is not only
community colleges it's
educational system --
In my work in my work for Syria
we have.
Lots and lots of school
districts.
And we have a youth council and
it meets every quarter and I
look around the room and at any
given --
Youth council meeting I might
have nine or ten superintendents
at that you've council meeting
and we have some community
colleges here we have got state
the Mingus there.
And they share ideas and and
share resources as to what some
colleges are doing and what
other school districts need to
be done.
We're in Lawndale now so said no
Union High School district is
one of my district they have
nine academies. For those kids
in high school plus way --
Occupational training programs
well we work very closely with
them we've provided many
employers and businesses to help
the cabin Mayes and that's
something that the work for the
board should be doing in are
doing.
Throughout the state but we need
the coordination.
SpaceX I was listening --
To the young lady to my right
over from SpaceX.
There is a program called non
destructive testing.
Through American technical
academy.
Well they're on our list of
providers.
And we've literally.
Trained dozens of people for
SpaceX for that occupation why
did we train them because
they're needed SpaceX told us
they're needed.
So -- We
work with the local businesses
that way we've connected SpaceX
with lots of the high schools in
the area so that they can work.
The engineering academies and
that only seven alibied else el
Segundo in Redondo Beach and
many other districts --
What is the what what the?
Is very important because now
what they're doing is setting up
certifications.
Not just degree programs but
certifications and what many of
the individuals need to I think
you're talking about today.
Our certifications to get a job.
I sure would like them all to
get college degrees but that's
not going to happen.
In their individuals that if
they're moving in the right
direction and getting a
certification in the area that
the employers in businesses need.
Then they're going to get a job
so we're setting up the
certifications working with the
colleges community colleges and
other schools so that after that
certification is finished.
They can get a job that's a we
wanna do not now because I
wanted to mention a couple of
the things.
Apprenticeship programs well.
Because of where we are there's
so much --
Construction going on a we're
getting it thousand people hired
at the very at the stadium in
the Hollywood park --
Program.
Many of them going into the
apprentice programs the majority
of them orientations every two
weeks.
But what we were thinking is
okay the a job in their premise
apprentice programs but we need
more apprentice programs.
So what we formed --
Couple years ago was a pre
apprenticeship --
Aerospace program engineering
program called Errol slacks.
And we had a hundred pre
apprentices go through that
program.
Now we have a fully blown
certified --
Flex are engineering apprentice
program for many of the defense
industry companies Boeing
Northrop impressa is a whole
list of them that we have.
We'd love to have space six join
us on and and what we want to do
is create a pool of individuals.
That they can go right into the
engineering program we had our
first apprentice --
In role just last month through
a company called Empresa locally
here in Gardena.
And we have the template.
For it has to be designed by
businesses that's the way it
works they control the
curriculum we have a consultant
work with them to help design it.
And then we pass it along to our
great community colleges to help
facilitate it down the line.
That works so well that we said
let's there let's use that
template and design other
apprenticeship programs.
Now we're working on a bio flex
program. For production
technician lab technicians in
partnership.
With supervisor mark Ridley
Thomas is very interested in
that we're working on that right
now a bio flex program down the
line we have applications.
Working with the state board
hopefully we get funded for a
cloud flex computer aerospace
prop --
Apprenticeship program as well
as a dental flex apprenticeship
program.
And transportation flex program
so we want to take this model we
want to do it in our area.
We want to do it in your area
head and Mike Gipson area roll
that out in the LA basin so the
LA basin hasn't.
Then roll that out to the state.
In our era flex program we're
getting calls from Florida from
other states that want to
replicate what we've done.
So I think we have the design
and again it has to be employer
driven that's the only way it
works so we're going to have
multiple apprenticeship programs
going down the line --
Another important thing is.
You know nowadays is a lot of
people working I mean we
certainly have those individuals
that are unemployed and we're
getting a marina employee.
Using the prison system running
special programs but many people
are working but what they need
is a lake up so that they can
keep going. One of the programs
that we have all to the problems
the state of California has one
is the employment training panel --
Camino.
Can help businesses when
employment training panel South
Bay workforce investment board
can help with --
Employment training panel to
help those businesses upgrade
skills.
But we also have on a regular
basis allocation 20%.
Of our fine in the adult pro the
program may be utilized for
incumbent workers.
So we can take individuals that
are working and have them
trained and many of this is
certificate programs that are
available and community colleges.
Maybe additional combined with
on the job training.
And be able to upgrade their
skills today and get them the
better wages and it's available
right now.
Is available and we're doing it.
All the time --
Ominous as assemblyman Gibson
said we were at the meet the
whole bunch of oil companies
yesterday.
In the past five years or so
we've placed over thirty three
thousand individuals and the
refineries.
Probably around.
Thirty five hundred so we have
ideas and what we want to be
doing with that witcher well
good paying jobs and and can
support themselves.
So there's very good things
going on the state of California
we want to keep it going want to
concentrate on the training.
And forget the paperwork and
let's go on and train people.
Thank you.
So I do have a question what.
In your experience what is the
final thing that drives
employers to actually come to
your door what is that final
step that makes them that.
They get tired of not having the
employees that they finally come
to and then to the employers
that are here with us today.
What could we do to get to maybe
to the workforce investment
boards a little sooner to create
that curriculum I realize it's a
lot of work?
I realize it's adjustment in the
model of what you've done in the
past what would incentivize and
is a little thing that they say
well.
I I think it's geared to showing
successes we have to show
successes and they need to hear
from the other businesses on
what's been able to be
accomplished.
And we have a list of businesses
that are willing to speak for us
and be able to talk to other
businesses about it because what
we want to do it we want.
To the workforce boards need to
do all the work they need to do
the paperwork they need to free
the employers up of of of the
bureaucratic stuff we'll we'll
take care of all that.
What they need to do is see the
results and when they see the
many people getting jobs when
they see the thousands of people
we've been able to get connect?
To construction and oil
companies and by the way with
all the construction.
That yields other jobs if you
construct something you need
support support people working
there and that's what we need.
So with that with the work force
binding with these academies
being --
Being built at various --
Public schools.
And working closely with their
work for sports in there one
stop centers --
Great things are happening here --
Organizations we partner with
those organizations the boards
have all those organizations on
our board we have the schools we
have a plan to develop a
different we have community
based organizations we have.
Almost any organization that
that that work force is
important too so they don't need
to go to other organizations I
need to go to the board.
And work with those boards and
tell them what they need and
those boards will deliver the
services for them.
I'm speaking of boards you have --
Is there chambers of commerce
relationship.
With the greater Los and Sam
ecommerce a the chambers of of
of clippers it you know a tell
you what we did a couple years
ago we had all the chambers of
commerce and are eleven cities
come to a meeting.
We invited all the economic
development administrators from
the eleven cities all sit down
together.
And some of the elected
officials a little Valentine was
at that meeting I seek
counseling about Tonya.
And we said the chambers and to
the economic development
directors of the city.
What can we do for you just like
we did with the health care you
tell us what you need?
And what they needed was mapping
they needed asset. For the
region to show where the spaces
are so instead of a business
moving out and moving to Texas
we could say wait a minute don't
do that.
You want to move out of the city
for some reason we have other
areas right your backyard.
So we created that for them --
Intern bàn study we did --
Throughout the South Bay because
was requested of us with South
Bay caught so we meet with the
chambers all the time bring them
together.
And we're here to support the
chambers one of the follow up
question you made mention about
the transportation program.
Can you Jess --
Tell me a little bit about the
transition from.
Well the purchase program there.
The what what the LA and by the
Federal Highway Administration
for example federal agency that --
Overseas a lot of the
construction going on came to us.
Because they said.
How are you doing this job by?
Being able to recruit all these
individuals and to construction
and transportation because
frankly federal highway
administration.
Looks to serve the underserved
individuals particularly African
American males women and they
haven't been able to do it.
We've we've have 80% of the
people that we recruited have
been underserved population we
just had a whole class of women
graduate and go into
apprenticeship program for the
construction.
So they designated --
Hollywood park project and LA
acts one of the LA X. projects
as pilot programs for FHA and
nay funded us a little bit of
money. To be able to keep doing
what we do those projects and to
provide the support services
necessary you know people have
to get from one place to another
well they have to do that we
have to figure out how best to
do it.
They need --
Money up front sometimes to join
the unions you know and that we
help them with that.
So on the FHA came to us and we
delivered they said we want we
want to deliver fifty people we
know you can't do it very fast.
Because it takes us a long time
will give you eighteen months we
didn't two months.
So -- And we
work with metro like I said LA
acts so --
And it all help because of that
construction projects that we're
doing we have orientation. Two
weeks so they know that were
there now in person will start
doing it once a month into it
it's every two weeks.
So it's a matter of getting the
word out getting the city
councils to announce it --
Getting billboards up if we care.
And and word of mouth they're
one of the my final comment one
of things that --
That I found out more more is
the lack of individuals with
their class a driver license to
become truck drivers now.
The drive up and down the
seventeen freeways wanted fifty
two thousand dollars a year all
you need is a class a driver
license.
I know there's a great
partnership that the California
trucking so station dot money
into the Long Beach City College
speaking them can connect in the
community college --
Where you can go get your class
A. Dr licensing --
Right into a job make it fifty
two thousand dollars a truck
drivers there's a lot of jobs
that's right billable.
But we have no qualify skill
individuals we have a class a
driver license so is that
something you can also look at
to try to connect and make a
real and relevant.
So there there's a list at the
state level it's called --
ETP L. it's a list of schools.
More schools are put on that
list from the South Bay
workforce investment than any
other area in the state we have
thousands of courses available
hundred to schools.
And some of those a truck driver
school some of them a great
truck driver schools if they
don't place the people we take
them off the list they have to
get jobs. For this two ways of
doing it somebody can go up the
street going to the training and
do that or hire some people at a
lower level.
Than we can use our incumbent
worker funds. To to provide
additional training for that
individual so they can go into
the truck driving once they're
already employed.
So there's two ways of doing
[inaudible]
Thank you.
Question.
Okay.
But more of a comment I mean
earlier we mentioned that.
Or someone had mentioned that we
need like a conduit right to
connect --
Business --
To community colleges it's for
sports right. Forty five work
was there that do it yeah there
already are there are salute
there is.
A work.
It's always a work sports so
every every area at every he
said geography and the state has
a work force support.
And they have one stop centers
or whatever the official name is
now American.
I always I think that the per
the successes that you've had
all of all the programs that you
listed.
You know how do you replicate
that in other areas.
Any place in itself could just
call us and we'll come up there
and help them I mean we all work
pretty closely together and
thinking of my areas. To call
you where I went when I
northeast San Fernando Valley.
In so where we have some
aerospace manufacturing LA city
at the city of LA yes so we work
we work closely with LA city and
all those the pre apprentice Y.
said this a hundred and eighty
pre apprentice slots.
Slots that are available right
through us so any workforce
board in the LA basin that wants
that individuals that want to
stick their toll on the water
see if it's for them.
We can enroll them into that
program right now.
Okay yeah will follow up okay
every time we have Janet a
meeting members try to steal
them from.
I'm gonna figures of sars he's
ours we Sharon.
Thank you Dan for everything you
do I we have a last speaker and
I know we're running out of time
in the room so I Ernesto Medrano
from.
The building trades thank you
for being here.
Thank you a similar burgers
memory of us assembly member
Gipson thank you have in the
building trades here --
The bill the first represent a
hundred forty thousand hard
working men and women and Ellie
in Orange County --
We represent about forty nine
organizations of all the fifteen
traits that are within the
building trades.
We have the greatest secret in
north American that as our
apprenticeship programs a lot of
people don't know about them.
And and blood that we're here to
go to talk for your degree
because we call it the other for
your degree in our friendship.
Goal to the apprenticeship work
earn as you learn and be able to
earn in the neighborhood of
about sixty to seventy thousand
dollars a year with no tuition.
Note that health care pension
all organized with all
represented to collective
bargaining and that's the bill
the trade talks --
We take individuals out of your
community out of poverty in
poverty level and we will put on
a path to middle class who are
training upper collective
bargaining process we invest
approximately.
Two hundred million dollars in
the state of California to our
front to training not public
money not tax money it is our
money that we negotiate
collectively with or signatory
employers.
We represent 91% of the state
certified of prizes not just
doesn't include construction of
other state certified a
partnership comes out of our
joint labor management schools.
And that comprises approximately
sixty thousand apprentices in
the process right now to what
the state of California --
We were very proud of what we do
we feel we're the best in the
business.
What you turnout junior level in
any of our trade you can go
anywhere in North America with a
journey level card go to Toronto
Canada?
Vancouver British Columbia you
can go to New York for political
Washington state and they'll
recognize in any local union
hall that you're and your trade.
And you can go son of the book
and be dispatched to go to work
because that's the kind of
training that we have uniform
throughout the country --
We always to provide a skilled
and trained workforce --
To to the industry and again it
will we train our folks we work
collaboratively.
And collegial with our signatory
minister number of
apprenticeship as there is now
we're the highest construction
boom since the nineteen twenties
then well were put a lot of
folks for apprenticeship.
In fact some of our facilities
here in southern California or
building on or acquiring other
facilities because the demand is
so high --
We also do our partnership
agreement for project labor
agreements we have.
Community elements which are the
local higher the veteran
preference for help hardhat
program will take a veteran we
are coming out of the military
for a program.
And provide him with direct
access into apprenticeship --
As well as the war project labor
agreements they get this batch
first -- As
well as whoever's on the local
higher --
Universe that we negotiate in
that agreement so --
We're very proud of the work
that we do with I know there was
reference to talk about the
apprenticeship reading this
correctly will sprout for
curriculum.
That was established for the
north American building trades
it's a minimum of one hundred
twenty hours it'll fulfill the
high school level will fulfill.
The eight three G. --
Entrance or requirements as an
elective and we're very proud of
that again as Chen was
mentioning that's a place where --
A young man or woman could go
and kind of as you say get your
toes wet figure out do I want
then you're walking
apprenticeship a student a leg
up and to come to our
apprenticeships.
We also partner with community
colleges we also partner partner
with your answer recidivism
coalition with --
Formerly incarcerated with the
flint ridge --
Center among many other
organizations from the basin now
let's talk about work
opportunities out there I'm
gonna rattle off a list of some
of the project labor grimaced
just in our area here around
here.
The port of Los Angeles for the
project labor agreements for
projects over two and a half
million dollars city of Los
Angeles.
But we have a project the break
room for all infrastructure work
over two and a half million
dollars at a close fire stations
parks water and sewer treatment
plants.
LA community college district we
have done the modernization of
all nine campuses with over ten
billion dollars a work to be
done there LA unified.
We build a hundred thirty one
you schools and modernization of
existence called approaching
twenty seven billion dollars
private work of to reference
earlier.
Which is the the rounds in the
charger stadium and award the
future clippers arena the future
upper to the form and that's all
local work with agreements with
local higher.
Again it was reference to the
finding all or refineries under
agreement of the Senate
California promoting a skilled
and trained workforce language
and thank you assembly member
Burke for supporting a chip
championing actually.
Senate bill fifty four that
enable us to be able to do that
city of Los Santos triple H.
project agreement to build
different tribes of homeless
support of housing.
And we're negotiations for the
city of Raleigh how would like
to do a lot of the have you and
your call assembly many of our
affront to supposed to I hope
when you get to interact with
your premise you get to see.
The work that we do that we've
been doing for many decades and
again we're the greatest hidden
secret so thank you for having
us here I'll take any questions.
Thank you for being here and I
am a huge supporter of the
building trades --
For my district you have been a
direct access to a lot of very.
Amazing great paying jobs that
that not just --
Take care of the person who's
getting a job with their
families as well so I've always
been a very proud supporter.
Of the building trades but who
do you have any idea how many
apprentices you have right now
and where they're coming from.
Italian Orange County with the
survey im gonna guess what five
years ago maybe six years ago.
And I think we had about four
thousand apprentices we did a
survey again about a year and a
half two years ago we had over
ten thousand a process.
I'm going to guess it's a couple
of thousand more than that so we
have.
It's called significantly and
others no went to it because of
the work that's out there in the
future.
And you know where they're
coming from how you're finding
them because I remember there
was a time you all struggled a
little bit with getting
apprentices and what the changes
been and how you've.
Been able to find them obvious I
mean it was reference of the
workforce development partner
with the workforce development
board.
Are agreements I think when we
partner with like a school
district a community college
municipality.
All the different stakeholders
in the community classes and so
it's a combination of the
community now rolling up our
sleeves and reaching out as as
much as we can to recruit folks.
I don't have a comment.
When I was on the city council
almost two years in Carson --
Through project labor agreements
for one and then also --
I think out to tour all the
princes programs was IBEW --
Pipefitters whatever --
They give especially those who
are recent incarcerated
opportunity I know the laborers --
They actually go into prison.
And take those brothers and
sisters out of prisons getting
released and move them right
into an apprentice program.
Which is again a look giving
those individuals the ability to
write a new chapter I'm for
their lives and also giving them
a decent living --
We just we talked about some
lifers who Jess got out and
they're in a program and those
individuals don't wanna go back
to prison and so this is.
Again.
Over a new leaf a right in
recent car.
Place into a German program
print program to get them and
that out Jan.
If they don't have their you
know their equipment having the
same conversation making sure
there's a strong coordination so
that no one falls through the
cracks because I think there's a
lot of jobs out here with with
the work that we've done in
Sacramento SP one and we're
we're our ability.
In the voters saving SP one and
there's a bunch of jobs we want
to make sure that we can team
keep people unemployed in
California so you do a great job
[inaudible]
Thank you.
I want to thank this panel thank
you for being here today thank
you for all the work you've done
and thank you.
For your investment in workforce
and the state of California we
have the next panel.
The next panel will come up.
And will it [inaudible]
The first
.
I don't me Jeffrey --
Reset.
Today say as seven oh sting us --
Assemblymembers Burke Reavis and
Gipson I'm I'm happy to join you
today --
From the California because
chances office so greetings on
behalf the chance that you
lawyer.
Oakley and also my executive
vice chancellor longtime
Quinlivan and I'm here to talk
development.
But before I tell you about
today I'd like you to play a
little game with me.
We're on the verge of the for
the Dodge revolution release has
been spoken as such and we can
take these little phones
nowadays and click them in the
head as in like what four years
which is an Olympic cycle.
Our technical assistance will be
here on the planet beaming in
through a virtual reality.
This building will be smart
interfaced.
So it's not just about how do I
get you a job today about how do
we actually creates for teaching
amounts for the state of
California because it's
workforce and economic
development.
So that's my favorite thing to
talk about is how are we
actually creating opportunity
they're expanding our economy
growing it verses just.
Taking time to the minimum spew
of it and saying are there
enough jobs.
Their jobs we are doing a great
job of matching them.
And the reason I think is we
think too much in terms of
occupation and not in terms of
skill.
In the article are the P. P. I
see report that was reported at
the top of this event.
There is a coherent says.
A workforce that cannot me or
retain sufficient training for
an in demand job is thus unable
to take advantage of economic
opportunities I think that's or
hearing.
And the next sentence that says
moreover.
The skills of the state's
workforce will have an impact on
California's national and
international competitiveness.
The failure to meet workforce
needs could limit or alter the
state's economic growth.
Didn't say occupation.
They said skills.
What needs to back improve is
are signaling between the
ecosystem of workforce
development community colleges
K.?
Twelve all of this and the the
kind of framework we talk about
it now so guided pathways how do
students understand what the
skills are in demand.
How is the economy and employer
signaling it?
And so we see some interesting
things.
Now we're having a great day and
workforce economical with me
colleges we went from two
hundred thousand invested in
workforce and economic five
years ago. To one point two
billion now and are for jobs in
the economy.
Framework to help us roll out
this in this this is where the
eight ecosystem conversation
comes into play where we've done
a lot of work in systems
development between.
The commuter colleges and
regions across the state as well
as industry sectors across the
state and that's where you're
hearing.
Some of these activities huge
investments and apprenticeships
especially new and innovative
apprenticeships and so there's a
lot of experimentation going on
and are job with the can you
college at the system level is
to see.
What's working and helping that
scaling grow and replicate words
words effective.
Now.
What we need to do is think of
education not as lego blocks
that we put together and
stackable credentials like put
these like was together we have
to think of it as a freeway
system?
Where when you want talk about
career technical education it's
that acceleration lane you get
on so you can go out speed on
the freeway to the destination --
Going.
And that we should continue to
be life long learners because
the demands.
From the economic development
that will see in the near future
is that the jobs of tomorrow
five years from now.
Don't exist today and so those
skilled dimensions of
occupations haven't been form so
how can education system which
takes two years to develop
curriculum.
Become responsive.
Those there are identify
people's reading as a more
discreet ways that we have a
student say taking a two year
study program.
Has to job out or quit.
They don't lose everything
there's some indication learning.
So using those little badges
they're actually using little --
Meta data points for learning
because we're not looking for
knowledge all the knowledge of
the universe is right here
Google answer that question for
you right now.
What we're looking for skills
which are performative?
And we need indicators that show
that I know how to perform. To I
know how to the piano looking at
me you couldn't tell but I could
show you if I could.
Well what if I could also
someone who knows what good
piano playing is certify my
ability to do so and give me
that a badge.
That represents that.
And so we see a lot of changing
going on in terms of what
reading this looks like for
students.
And most of its around
reputation management like
linkedin profiles or purfling
profiles where they can show.
Actual skills and I think the
key is that it has we work and
learned we can't afford to put
students for two years.
In a tacit knowledge experience --
The actual skills that they will
be compensated for so we see
more and more --
Work based arrangements --
Concurrent enrollment is also
another huge --
Track we seen education trying
to push people through the
curricula process quickly but
also to give them the actual
performance of skill sets they
need to the job.
So much easier to get a job if
you're already working in the
workplace and people know you
and you understand the process.
Than it is to go through for
your bachelor's degree and then
just gone to the market hope you
got hired.
So those are some of the trends
research and commute call as we
continue to do all all these
ecosystem developments I think
there's opportunity to further
develop the economic side of the
house in terms of the ecosystems
there between the ET seize the
CDCs on that.
ABC's and really take a very
very strategic approach to
whites and like.
We all who's better positioned
in this in the nation to leave
before the dust especially with
our new online conference space
college and positioning
ourselves to drive that economy
through town development.
And business opportunity
entrepreneurship mindsets and so
I think that is really the story
to be telling about how.
Can you colleges should be
moving forward into tomorrow but
in today were having a great
opportunity to have a lot of
funds available overseeing great
outcomes.
And you for a lot of those with
our partners today and I'm just
hoping to inspire a vision for
what we could really do with it
large capacity of the community
college system.
Unlike anywhere in the world
have you ever --
Fifteen colleges like this.
Sell parts are partners with CSU
and you seen how much we partner
with them in terms of producing
pathways.
So that's our mantra renown are
marching terms is guided
pathways help students find
their path through.
As well as provide wraparound
services that ensure that the
complete.
Thank you okay.
That's amazing at other.
I was amazing but so they just
tell me I'm running late so I'm
gonna have everyone speak and
then we'll come back to
questions --
Jessica cam.
Thank you know I'm.
So I'm just Google cam and the
director of workforce
development at the a Sanders
county economic development
corporation.
And I am excited to share with
you guys how we as a region are
responding to the future work.
So here the only be in as many
of you know we are quite large
and bass and complex we have
twenty one community colleges
over seventy five colleges and
universities. Seven workforce
development board's at the forty
America's job centers hundred
dollar ad eighty one keep your
total school district center
others use our unions are
community based organizations.
And so forth and they're all
being asked to connect to
industry be industry driven
demand driven put industry in
the middle.
Strength in your industry
partnerships we saw he the
twelve our workforce important
each industry so our industry
partners as an economic
development corporation --
Like can I just talked to one if
you right --
And so in our region.
If we're going to be demand
driven in terms of our work
force an education system that
we need to start with the
research in applied work so what
are what is the future for the
labor and the demand.
Side the supply.
So what we're doing as Ellie EDC
is working with our community
colleges to take a look at our
the over producing under
producing what are it to the new
clothes a course open of course.
What is the future of work were
also to having that same car
received in with a workforce
development board's in providing
a study that allows them to take
that labor market information?
And think the future of working
be demand driven and we are now
engaging with our CSU system are
California State University to
have that same conversation so
that they have the right labor
market information. To think
about the future of work and
talk about things like
automation tax.
That research that informs our
strategic industry engagement so
the center for competitive work
force is the largest LA regional
strong work force project.
Amongst the nineteen colleges
and it's a strategic partnership
between the nineteen community
colleges of the alley --
C. R. C. Ellie EDC the center of
excellence the research arm of
the commute colleges.
And Ellie chamber.
And its strategic in the sense
that we came together.
To partner across the industry's
stream Keats men and not
duplicate and to understand what
are the competencies we need.
For on what it is not.
In it for market.
Yes.
Information with Everitt.
I'm up.
Comes industry councils so
beyond jazz --
A part of the industry gauge men
is we only want to talk about
your work force needs for an
employer that could also be a
put off very.
A part of the industry
engagement is to look
holistically about what do you
have tax incentive means land
use issues workforce issues and
to talk about it as
comprehensive to me employer.
And to speak their language and
then to bring that back to the
system -- In
addition it also informs our
workforce development council so
we invite the entire work force
and education community in LA
county to a quarterly meeting.
To talk about regional industry
engagement regional industry
business intelligence
initiatives that cross across
the system.
And then to also hear back from
everybody about what additional
information what competencies
who are you engaging as an
employer can folks come to that
meeting.
And so we have pro actively side
we will partner to host these
meanings so that we can house
one conversation about advanced
manufacturing technical means.
I'm and all of the strategic
industry engage trees so --
Our bio are aerospace are --
Transportation and so forth.
And all of this then informs our
transactional work size I
mention for CCW the center for
competitive work force that goes
into the course development.
Employment engagement the work
based learning the internship
opportunities are industry
councils is also the business
assistance that they may need.
And formalizing these industry
feedback loops that are open for
anyone to attend and we do know
we share back with the community.
We also men for workforce
development council then is to
bring not online meant to take
the funding and see where we can
all partner.
And so as another part of the
center for compatible force that
we identified is C. C. W. smart
match.
So we also realize in talking
with industry they may have high
school internships are work
first of imports do a great job
there's alley summer you've
higher here in the region.
College and universities have
internship programs in our
graduate schools but what
doesn't exist or the community
colleges and so.
We talked to employers about
there's a half million folks
being served in our region if we
include Orange County we talk
about three quarters of a
million individuals of a talent.
That you are not tapping into
and so talking to them about
internships levering our
employer relationships so that
we're talking about closing the
skills gap.
I mourn and most importantly in
order for us to be demand driven
industry responsive future
forward in adoptive we also
believe we need to connect in
real time as the former panel
had discussed.
So we're creating any if which
is the regional CRM more LED
sees committed to push regional
business intelligence.
Our community colleges are all
committed to being on it I mean
gauging our workforce
development board's to also use
their regional funding to invest
in it as well so that.
Throughout our entire workforce
and education system we'll be on
one portable so an employer like
Mister Dawson from chevron can
come in and say Hey I'm looking
for P. tack who has P. tack.
And in real time our entire
workforce education system will
get that message and be able to
reply an LED see on the back and
will be able to monitor that to
make sure there is a quick
response.
And so we do this easy W..
I need with the teens every
other week --
To go over it so when I'm
talking about taking this
knowledge and connecting it back
to the system it's an actual
formalized loop --
And so we are hoping.
LED see would also like to
recommend when we envision
workforce provided for keep to
twelve the community colleges
the workforce development board
I'll have this funding telling
regionally.
And to engage industry the boat
we would also be bold enough to
ask that we consider for a cal
state university system that the
same type of investment.
Is also made because a lot of
the courses are thought to be
matriculating upwards and so for
leaving them out of the equation
number leaving out that box are
degreed.
Opportunity which we now the
higher level of education behind
median weights and so we in the
region have the CSU.
Five so the five CS use in our
region have connected you. To
the relay institute and so my
job an LED sees to know about
all that I have the fortune of
being mentored under dam vocal
and formally working at south be
with him.
And so if you're actually
wondering if this happens it
definitely does --
I don't know if you've heard
about the Amazon web services
that the cloud computing
certificate that was developed
at a Santa Monica college.
Is being replicated by on
nineteen in the region so if you
live in Compton you don't have
to drive Santa Monica college
and also because there elation
agreements.
And then based upon the great
error flax model that's out the
we've created we reach out to
them to talk about clout flax
and how do we bring the work
force boards into the
conversation as well.
And take advantage of that and
so what you're seeing in LA
county is that there is this
cross system alignment this
regional engagement but it also
comes at the expense of
investing in this infrastructure.
So that it can be continued
replicated an employer can just
go to one place to share an
opportunity and get a response.
Thank you.
Thank you at Dr rack.
Hi -- I'm a
the dean of business at a Camino
college and I do work closely
with Jessica and I worked with
her at Nguyen and Janet the web.
And I'm working with their the
LA the EDC and on the center for
competitive workforce and
various other things so --
I would like to say that I am
thrilled to see the emphasis on
career technical education.
It's something in which I
strongly believe I am a product
of the community college I went
to El Camino college.
He got.
And the degree in paralegal
studies [inaudible]
I went.
Law school.
Paralegal left debt so I would.
Love to help other students do
the same thing.
So I I know the value of getting
a skill.
And using that skill to help put
yourself through.
Through --
Getting a career and that then
that getting even moving up the
scale as you go along --
We actually don't Camino have a
couple of of new --
Programs that I think will help
others do that you can stop
along the way --
Use that skill for moving up to
type one ago.
And one of them is what Jessica
brought up in that is the a WS a
cloud certification.
Program that is a we are one of
the nineteen that is involved in
that.
All of our curriculum has passed
through curriculum we will be
offering the first courses in
fall.
Of for that program and we're
really excited about that one of
the interesting things about a
W. S. was that it's not a huge
monetary commitment --
It's a development curriculum
and a very dedicated faculty
member.
Who is willing to go for the
certification --
Who is willing to develop the
curriculum to guided through and
to get started?
And to be involved with the
other nineteen schools to make
sure that we are on board.
And they are all working as a
team and I think it's it's been
touted as the first time that's
ever happened.
So it's it's always interesting
to see and and it all started
with Santa Monica which I think
if if you happen to know much
about community colleges that's
supposed to be a big competitor.
So -- We're
we're thrilled to be were was to
be Amazon --
They were --
You know telling us what they
needed -- To
be able to certify these people
to work for them so that is
going to be we think huge --
When I talk with --
Santa Monica they opened their
first class it was filled within
an hour of opening it so.
That the statistics are think
was it two thousand jobs.
And is two thousand jobs
available a month --
In aid of U. S. so we're we're
looking --
Of course now that's going to
spread around all nineteen
colleges so --
But but that is that you know it
that I think that there's a huge
opening and the the north far
north is starting to ask how can
we replicate what you're doing
down there so we're we're we're
excited about it. One of the
program --
I'm going to mention it is up
and running --
Has been and is has is --
Expanding we just offered our
first on ethical hacking class
we've been offering the the the
first classes in that but this
is that --
Ethical hacking class so I that
also I think is going to be one
we expand upon and are able --
To show a lot of of of promise
in in --
Cyber security --
As you know.
Everywhere you go there's
everybody's being hacked --
And I read everything so --
There's a lot of opportunity and
that from from the entry level --
Up is as high as you want to go.
So -- Those
are just a couple of the courses
that were involved in in those
courses were made possible --
Certain the A. W. S. was made
that we got through strong work
force -- And
the strong workforce money has
been very very helpful to us the
cybersecurity program was made
made possible through Perkins
funding.
So -- That's
however we coordinating the
solutions --
We are working again through
strong work force --
Where are you on strong pathways
with pathways?
Being --
Right now we're working with
that those plan is.
To and to my to show students
these are the possible careers
that are out there this is what
you would need to do.
Familiarize them what is out
there I think we're finding that
they get to high school and I
have no clue what occurred this
I want to be this --
But have no idea what that
entails so --
Try to familiarize them with
with this would entail and this
is the kind of career you would
have this is how much money you
might make and these are the
kinds of classes you would need
to take because she's if you.
Want to be a brain surgeon you
need to know you're going to see
some blood you're going to need.
To know a lot of science and
math and things change while
you're still in high school.
So is so is there's a lot of
things that that they need to to
know and and we help.
To guide them to help them along
that we also are --
Are working with the with --
And that was a contract we
entered into is just going to
still with the web and that is
they they will be doing some
career fairs for us they will
they are a focused career fairs.
Where they will come on campus
and? Eight eight for of and
they're convene the employers
for I bring them on campus and
then we will of course bring the
students and they some of them.
Actually higher that days some
of them just takes --
Resumes and things but it's a
way to try to connect to
students with the employers --
We also are --
Part of the regional --
Project that is a job developer
we are in the process right now
of hiring a job developer that
job developer will work with the
industry.
They will work with the way ups
they will work with LA EDC they
will work with the others to try.
To coordinate with industry to
try to bring lawyers --
To understand the kinds of jobs --
We are are helping students
prepare for and to to post jobs
on campus so that students who
are going to school who are
graduates whatever will have
access. To two jobs we are also --
Part of the C. C. W. --
We're doing deep dives into
various professions and making
that available to students to
faculty to to everyone else --
We are part of the job speaker --
It's another regional where jobs
speaker will be available to
students will be available --
To faculty in their classes
where job speaker is a software
where students can post the
skills they have attained.
In their classes and similar --
To a Jeff was talking about
where you you --
I took this class these are the
skills I say this is the job
that I'm looking for in these
the skills I need a wait I see a
student here has the skills.
Connects the two and a so it's
something that they can do on
their own it's not something
that we would.
Require that they go through us
to do so it's also something are
job developer would be involved
in to to try to help them. To to
to coordinate that another --
Thing that we're involved in is
the regional marketing we the
region --
Put three million dollars into
marketing and to help market up --
All of the programs in the
region that still we're still
working on that and hope that
that that's going to be huge to
bark at all the programs.
In the region.
Thank you.
RO last panelist Merion humor
hill was probably sick of us at
this point we we see her.
We we ask her to come to
everything's.
Thank you for being here today.
Thank you very much for having
me -- Night
of it to share a couple things
about myself because I have a
connection to each of you in
different ways --
Currently I am the executive
director propel a which is the
team supporting and the
implementation of our county
wide strategic plan which has
seven big goals the goal one is
all about investing in our
people.
And that has to do a lot with
strengthening our work force and
our education systems and we
have the privilege of working
with our stakeholders were
involved in early childhood K.
through twelve with the
community colleges with the
excuse used other universities.
At all with adult of a multi
service poverty relief agency in --
Assemblymember group me this is
districts --
Called meant to meet each need
with dignity he served at that
average of thirty seven thousand
low income clients per month.
And many of them are working
poor and so I'm absolutely
passionate about what it takes
to lift people out of poverty
were making. Twenty thousand
dollars a year less.
What will it take to bring them
into a livable wage jobs?
And so I'd like to focus my
comments on adult education as a
resource that is kind of a
silent partner in the work force
system often unrecognized
unknown.
And yet --
For three reasons I feel like
this is a a resource that is
particularly well suited. To to
to pulling in that particular
workforce for the technical jobs
that we have of the future --
First of all accessibility there
a lot of adult eight campuses
that are in low income
communities or their operating
classes in local neighborhood
schools where people can go this
morning I checked and where I've
worked at men --
It would take three buses to get
to the nearest community college
and forty five minutes to an
hour most of our clients.
Came to our ESL classes are
computer classes.
By foot they walked where they
rode bicycles.
And the accessibility is really
critical particular --
Population.
Approachability --
You know for many of our clients
they were immigrants from Mexico
and from Central America
[inaudible]
And I know because I know a lot
about committee colleges I know
that our community colleges
could meet their workforce needs.
But I also know that their
mentality was such that.
They didn't see themselves yet
as college material I'm they
distancing themselves as being
college but that wasn't part of
their thinking.
And in --
Adult add this kind of that
bridge that gives them
confidence through an ESL
program or through high school
equivalency where they can say
yes now I'm ready to go to a
community college but that that
approachability factor is a big
deal -- In
that community.
And then affordability --
Up on of the options --
For career technical education
adult education is the least
expensive.
And in many cases free at all
for this particular population
so -- I feel
strongly that we need to do all
that we can to narrow the gap
between rich and poor that
equity factor that's so much a
part of our life here in Los
Angeles.
And I you know I see adult ed
here in in LA for example LA
unified school district which is
got that one of the biggest
programs for adult at in the
state --
Their training about thirty
seven thousand students English
right now --
Throughout our county it's about
a hundred and ten thousand
students are getting ESL classes
through our community colleges
as well as through adult ed.
But there's one point five
million people are county that
don't speak English for don't
speak it well how do we reach
them so that we can then prepare
them. For those jobs of the
future -- I
think we really need to expand
that.
Apprenticeships --
Adult it has the largest
apprenticeship program in
California with sixty one trades
represented.
And for that are under
development seventy five hundred
students.
So -- So
they're well positioned again to
meet this particular population
so my courage meant would be
that we increase the adult ed
block grant ABG which is AB --
One oh for in the coming --
Fiscal year --
Of our lowest income residents
in our region [inaudible]
Thank you.
Thank you any questions comments
[inaudible]
Not.
We're running a time so at this
time will invite anyone who
needs to make wants to needs to
make public comment.
If we have any I don't even know
where they going.
Out.
No no one is make a comment.
There.
Yeah Hey okay --
With that I would like it if
there's no further questions or
comments I like to give you a
chance to close --
The all of you today --
I want to thank you.
For all the information that you
provided in all of the insight --
My most of my career I've worked
in K. through --
Twelve education and I'm really
stem education and thinking
about the future work force --
But now as an assembly member I
have constituents that. One of
you know they're not the not
just about the future they're
thinking about the present and
like adults is definitely
something that I'm.
If we want families to have a
better life of or quality of
life for children we need to
think about the adults and and
they're the current career and
not just the children's future --
In so.
The is the thank everyone for
being here is not just this.
This issue is I'm very
passionate about it to you to
workforce development and
especially highly skilled jobs --
Into one thing.
Of the Queen Mary on what you
were mentioning I know we have --
The connection because of the
community and men --
But also thinking of non English
speaking adults right where.
If you before thinking like --
Jeffrey said about skills rate
and skills do you necessarily
have to speak English to develop
that skill and and I know I grew
up in Pacoima an I know a lot of
people in the community to have
skills --
And are ready for the work force
but the barrier is maybe taking
the English class at the
community college level or you
know if that.
What may be required and of more
of the skill and so how do we?
Like a badgers certify them and
and the way that.
Some employers they just want to
hire someone that knows how.
To do the particular skill has a
skill read --
In so -- You
don't think you.
I think all of you combined I
think are having right now I'm
thinking about what we can do
and and I definitely want.
To stay in touch with you and
collaborate so thank you
[inaudible]
Gipson.
Thank you very much first I want
to say thank you to our
chairwoman and to also member
revised.
And falls of the great Pat a
what the great information you
provided for us --
I represent the six poorest
issue can entire state of
California so jobs is very very
important --
To the people which I represent
what I unemployment rate was
eleven point 9% today as hover
around for I'm skews me six
point 3% of my district --
That's still not good enough I
wanna make sure --
That we have is a a work force a
skillful workforce that can meet
the growing demands --
Specially here in California
California's growing.
By leaps and bounds and there's
a number of jobs that people are
not qualified and skillful
enough to do those kinds of jobs.
So the work in the conversation
we have today is very very
important I look forward to
working with --
Both of these --
Vivacious a courageous women
here moving --
Possibly public --
Policy --
For the next legislative session
two thousand nineteen to help
move us for so again thank you
very much for all the to
contribute today and other for
working with each. One of you in
two thousand nineteen happy hour
spent -- I
mean how do you beat that I just
I want.
You know when that my mom used
to state not to meet with she
said.
She would be out speaking and
she would say you've nap to
young people and she would say I
promise you you've never heard
of what you're going to do by
the end of your career.
Unfortunately for me that is not
what happen to me I heard.
I had heard of this job before
because she had it --
But yet here we are --
Will have million jobs in two
thousand twenty five that will
need a certificate or less to
fill them --
We are also at the lowest
unemployment we have seen in a
very long time yet we are
struggling still with the
highest.
Poverty and obviously each one
of our panelists are doing
incredible work toward making
sure that that no longer that
continues to be the case --
We are past the point of wanting
peace it is now coming on us to
make sure people have careers.
Not just living livable jobs but
real career some real
opportunity and I want to think
everyone on the panel for the
entire day for that.
I'm your continue commitment and
I reiterate what us only member
gives in and and lose and we
never reva said which is.
The hopes of today are that
we've gotten some information to
move some legislation to help
you do your job a little easier --
To make it a little more
streamlined for you to see six
that's because when you all see
six at the state of California
truly sees great success so
thank you for everything you do.
Thank you for being here thank
you both assembly members for
being here today and with that
we are adjourned things have a
great holiday [inaudible]
Well -- But